four three
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from their dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i am john
delona here with my good friend
best-selling author number one
youtube star the one and only mr anthony
o'neil
we're taking your calls on life on money
helping you with
anything that's going on in your heart
in your home in your pocketbook
anthony how are we doing this today
i need to cut on the mic yeah there we
go this is my first time on the show
since the new year's and i forgot how to
cut on the mic
all right not cut on turn on the mic uh
got to work on my grammar
i like cut on hey man listen i gotta get
better um i'm doing well man
you know it's a beautiful beautiful time
to just really reset
refocus and to get it going man so i'm
excited just to be doing what i do with
you all and with dave and so i'm excited
to help some people out today
very cool all right let's go out to
tyson in chicago illinois tyson how are
we doing
i'm doing pretty good how are you guys
outstanding good man how can we help
um so i am 15 and i've been mowing lawns
since i was 12.
i am looking to take my small business
to the next level i have found to my
friends who are interested in
partnering with me and we would mow
about three areas across a
20 mile area and i'm wondering
what we should do and do we need to file
for an llc and what should we do about
taxes
stuff like that oh man that's that's a
great question uh tyson have you uh
purchased my um teen entrepreneur
toolbox kid
i haven't okay yeah i'm gonna send you
one i want you to stay on the line
uh when we get done talking with you
kelly will get you one because you
actually you're asking a lot of great
questions
um no i do not want you to get an llc
okay i want you to
do a dba okay and i'm gonna walk you
through exactly
how to do that because i want you to
avoid fees and really when it comes to
teen
entrepreneurship it's really about
learning the mindset of the entrepreneur
while also doing the work and while also
being legal
so i'm going to show you how to do all
three of those things but
here's one thing i want to caution you
with you you're going into business with
three
friends what i want you to do is really
focus on
uh just how do you do it yourself one
and maybe
another friend but now this is three
friends three different families
and i like how you're dreaming you
you're you're expanding already but
i would really want to encourage you to
start off yourself maybe within a 10
mile radius
maybe pick up 10 clients figure things
out for yourself as a business
then com then bring in friends once you
really know how to do it but
i love the way you're thinking already
man how many clients do you have already
tyson
um so i have about four that i do
currently this past summer i made about
two thousand okay doing that
so that's been pretty good and so when
you say next level what does that mean
tyson
well i mean like what we were thinking
about is uh
you know doing some marketing and uh
making like shirts with the company name
and logo on it and
website stuff like that no
no mate you i know the younger
generation thinks like
shirts and stuff like that is cool great
right now you need to be generating
money
not uh setting up things it's going to
take away from your money
now if you want a shirt just so you look
good when you out there cutting grass
that's great
um i have no problem with that get you a
nice little shirt
snap a logo on there and be good right
now i'm thinking about how do you pick
up more clients
okay two thousand dollars and cutting
grass is great but you'll see inside the
teen entrepreneur toolbox kit
there's a guy just like you started at
15 he was making forty thousand dollars
a year
cutting grass but he kept his expenses
very minimum
and he had close about 35 clients that
he was cutting every single week
then check this out tyson uh in the
winter months
he went and he didn't cut grass he went
and shoveled snow
so depending on where you are he adapted
to the season and kept his expenses low
so
i want you to stay on the line kelly's
going to get you the teen entrepreneur
toolbox kid
i'm gonna teach you everything i'm gonna
teach you how to secure the bag at a
young age
and you're gonna be straight thank you
and tyson
go knock on the door today and get one
more job okay
no t-shirts no no advertisement no
secret facebook campaigns just go knock
on a door
and you've got it all right let's go to
courtney in detroit courtney how are you
doing
i'm doing well john and anthony how are
you great deal
how can we help god
so i'm going through an interesting
season 2020 was
beautiful and so i'm going through a
divorce
i'm sorry yeah thanks and i have
some significant mental health issues
and i'm looking to start over
um but i'm trying to figure out
what that looks like for a house and how
much i should pen and
how long i should wait sorry i know
that's a lot but
yeah yeah i mean it's such a great
question how is your divorce process
going right now is it
at least moving smoothly i know it's
probably not the greatest experience but
is it is it going smoothly at least
yeah i just printed out the paperwork
online um we don't have any kids or
anything
okay all right all we have is a house
together so
and you're gonna sell the house yes sir
okay cool
and what's your income right now i just
got a
fifteen thousand dollar raise so i'm at
60 grand
60 grand so that means you're about like
50 grand um
probably 46 47 uh yeah yeah how much
debt are you in after the divorce
um the door should pay off everything uh
so i sold my car
um i'm renting right now for about a
thousand dollars a month
okay and uh should net about 12 to 15
grand
uh from the sale of the house should
have a little bit of a down payment
okay cool before we think about a down
payment what's going to be in your
savings account
that's funny um well
that's the timing thing so 10 grand and
then saving up for the down payment
there you go you just said exactly what
i was going to tell you
i think right now with you uh coming out
of divorce i'll let uh
john check in with you on the divorce
side of things but from a practical
practical side of things
um i want you to take that money from
the divorce make sure you pay off all of
your personal debt
all right because you're going to be
ahead of the game with with the average
person who leaves
um a marriage normally they leave their
marriage
with stress with debt with issues so
you're leaving
unfortunately in a good good way in a
healthier way so what i want you to do
is go ahead and put that money in your
savings account go ahead and establish
at least three to six months
and then after that let's go ahead and
start pocketing money um for a down
payment
but if i was you i'm gonna sit for two
years and see where is my life
going uh from here um and
it sounded like you was like oh but
there's nothing wrong with dating
a long time yeah well it's a long time
to make sure that you are going to be
in detroit michigan or uh you may
find you someone and you may be moving
so i mean i would say give you
give yourself some time to adjust to
your new life
save up for a down payment then once
you're in a healthy place okay i'm gonna
be here
um i'm in a healthier place i'm healed i
can think straight
then yes go ahead and get you a house i
think anything that's so
wise when you're coming off a divorce
it's so
tempting to want to jump into the next
stable thing
and you end up jumping in into water
that is way too deep you to swim
courtney you've got to grieve the loss
you got to get your hands
and heart and health back you got to get
your head around the mental health
issues go see
a professional get your head on that
screw on straight anthony is dead right
two years minimum before you buy a house
you need to get your soul back
and then you can start thinking about
buying a house
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend blinds.com
is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop lines
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm dr john
doloni
and i'm joined here by my good friend
and fellow ramsay personality
best-selling author mr anthony o'neill
we are taking your calls about life
making calls about your money think
calls about anything that's going on in
your heart and mind
we are here for you let's go to the
phones let's go to kevin in bentonville
arkansas
kevin what's going on man how can we
help hey fellas
so a couple years ago i co-signed a loan
with my
son's mother because she didn't really
have any options due to her credit
and here recently she has
been defaulting on the payments and it's
really wrecking my
credit so i was just calling to see like
what options i had available
to try and uh get my name off that and
get everything fixed up for me
man so let's break this down uh one more
time
you cosign or they cosign on something
for yourself
i co-signed for them okay and what you
cosign for what what is it
it's a car okay cool how much is the car
payment
uh it's about 250 a month okay 250 a
month all right
how much longer do you have how much
longer do you all have to pay on the car
uh there's about seven or eight thousand
dollars left
so not a ton but uh
because she hasn't been paying it lately
it's really takes my credit i was
uh right at about 700 and now i'm below
600.
okay all right understandable what's
your uh financial situation at right now
how much money do you make a year
uh my net last year was about 35
35 000. 35 000. okay how much money do
you have in the savings right now
uh so my savings i just wiped it out
because i just bought a house
ah okay all right so you have zero okay
yeah all right
uh so here's the thing i'm not gonna
dive into the on the deep end side of
why we teach people to not do cosigning
because
you've already done it so i don't want
to i don't want to feel like we are
attacking you in this one but this is
one reason why we say do not do it
number two right now there's nothing you
can do
you know really the only thing you can
do is make the payment
uh you signed the piece of paper saying
hey if something happened
i will make the payment so legally right
now
you need to make the payment of 250
and get it caught up i'm not really
concerned about my credit score
what i'm concerned about is i don't want
nothing coming uh
after no one coming after me to recoup
this balance once it goes to collection
i don't want no one calling me and my
family
bugging me about someone else's car
stuff but i signed up for that
as a co-signer so with that being said
i'm going to advise you right now have a
conversation with the
individual you co-signed for get a game
plan and say hey listen i have to step
in
but everything that i do pay eventually
we're going to have to talk about okay
how am i going to get this money back
but unfortunately right now the only
thing you can do kevin
is just step in make the payments or pay
it off but right now you're not in a
financial position
to definitely pay it off so you need to
make those payments
do you sign up for it as a co-signer
bottom line
okay so do you get that thank you yeah
you got that there is no magic
magic pill here no no silver bullet on
this one
just got to bite the bullet right and
and that's what a co-signer is right
anthony
it's the bank says i'm not going to give
her the money i'll give both of you the
money right well you're on the hook for
it then and here's the thing
and this is why i teach people um
especially like my generation are you in
my generation yeah of course i am how do
you 59 oh yeah definitely to my
generation
uh not really i'm not 59
i know you're not you're my generation
i'm 27 right definitely not 27. but
like i was saying um this is why i teach
our generation specifically that 20 30
young 40s to avoid cosigning
everyone has good intentions up front
okay
but life does happen and the last thing
you want to do
is go into something thinking it's good
and a dream turns into a nightmare a
kind gesture turns into
a wrong gesture you have to start
thinking about your future
what you want to do and at the end of
the day you do not want to co-sign
someone being a slave to a lender right
okay and so for me no i'm not gonna
co-sign for
for you john to get a car because for
one i don't believe in debt and so i'm
not gonna help you do something that i
believe in right
i don't believe in and so you want to
avoid that and then let's say if i did
do that i don't want
down the road life happen to you i'm
over here living good with my wife my
kids and we're going after our future
we're building our wealth then all of a
sudden i get a call saying hey
uh john missed his payments and we're
about to repo the car and this is about
to hurt you and your situation that's
right
and so um we really have to start
thinking
that there's nothing wrong with saying
no because saying no
actually helps the individual no it's a
gift and man think of kevin's heart here
his the the the mother of his kid
needs to get from a to b yeah he wants
to help out
yeah and what he's done down the road
has hurt both of them yeah right
yeah yeah yeah he really has man do
not co-sign hey banks aren't your friend
right we think of banks as our
friend they're not they are trying to
make money off of you banks are banks
are a tool because we all need a bank
that's right they're not our friend
and so if a bank won't loan your buddy
money
think about it right why should you
right right right the bank has done the
math and said
that probably not gonna pass back here's
the truth i won't even loan my friends
money
no i'll give you the money or we'll walk
away if i can't if i if i cannot afford
to give it to you
then i'm not gonna i'm not gonna loan it
to you at all because i don't want to
screw up my friendship that's exactly
right man
i don't have time for that all right
let's go to kevin in boston kevin how
are we doing
hey uh not too bad how are you doing
john anthony out standing outstanding
how can we help
yes um so i am on baby step two
um and i have uh my federal student
loans
uh sandwiched in between my my consumer
debt and then my private student loans
um i don't know if i should um postpone
the federal student loans due to the um
biden administration
now all sorts of okay
no no no so pretty much just just go for
it
yes listen and this has nothing to do
with biden this has nothing to do with
president trump this has nothing to do
with that
do not wait on the government to take
care of your house bottom line
right okay and let's just say biden and
his administration present something to
the congress it still has to get
approved through the congress
and studies have shown us facts have
shown us uh
student loan forgiveness is not
happening now i'm not saying it
cannot happen in the future but what i
am saying is
man you you sound like a smart young man
you sound like you know exactly what you
need to do
what i'm saying is you start going down
the journey to take care of your house
and then if the government does do
something
to they do forgive they do do some stuff
like that then yes take advantage of it
but as of right now do not postpone your
future
at the possibility of what the congress
and what the president administration
may do
uh because of showing this it may not
happen bro and kevin
right this is just this is a character
question
yup did you walk in to an office and
look down at a piece of paper
and sign your name and say you're going
to help me go to school i'm going to pay
you back
yes or no wait sorry
can you repeat that question
if i walk into an office did you walk
into your financial aid office
and you look down the piece of paper and
somebody that you don't even know
said i'm gonna give you the money to go
to school and you said i'm gonna pay you
back
i'm gonna sign my name to this piece of
papers assuring you that i'm gonna be a
person a character and pay you back
no yeah after reading um dave's book
yeah that's
that's not what i should have done in
this instance is that what happened
uh yeah it pretty much is yeah i was a
little naive to sign yeah
yeah we all were we all were we all were
right we're on the same boat
i had a bunch of zeros after my loans
but the reality is like anthony said
waiting for some
some dragon to come through and you know
some fairy godmother to come take away
what you said you were going to do you
said yeah
i'm going to pay for it to me it's a
character issue man do the best you can
get that paid off keep it in line and
then keep rocking and rolling man
you know we'll talk about this after the
break because i agree with you 50
it's a character issue because the other
50 of why i do not agree it's a
characteristic because i think a lot of
these young people don't know what they
did oh i agree
there's some predatory there's a
predatory part to it no question yeah so
it's like
50 yeah character issue 50 is naive just
didn't know that's right
you know what i'm saying so yeah i got
you i got you but let's talk about the
break because yeah we have some fun with
that one because i
love i love my people i love my people
too but pay your bills
you said you're going to pay pay i know
we tricked you
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
so
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
dolone joined here by ramsey personality
and best-selling author mr anthony
o'neill
we're taking your calls on life taking
your calls on money
triple eight 825-5225 it's triple eight
eight two five five two two five or you
can contact us
at ramsay's show speaking of at ramsay
show
anthony your youtube channel continues
to
lose its mind our friends and colleagues
their youtube channels are going great
what's going on in your youtube world
man hey man i'm excited today we crossed
200
000 subscribers 200 000
yeah man we just launched this channel
about a few years ago did about 150
000 subscribers last year and uh
just really excited man what i'm seeing
within my tribe within
you know my brand is we have this 18 to
about 40 year old individual that is
saying you know what
i'm sick and tired of this norm i really
want to get out of debt or avoid that
and start building well start a business
um at a young age and so we just have
this huge movement of young people
hungry
both black white hispanic mexican you
name it um
young all the way up to about 39 i would
say to be honest
who's an ao we're down with the cause we
want to be real we want to be relevant
we want to be righteous
but we want to build wealth so we can
start creating generational wealth and
so
um i want to encourage everyone two
things number one i want you to go watch
the uh my most recent show with my
my good friend your good friend chris
hogan he and i sat down and talked for
about 35 minutes on here's how you're
gonna win with your money in 2021
i'm already about 40 000 views that just
came out this week and i mean
you just see young people getting
excited excited excited and so
here's one thing parents if you're
listening to this i want you to write
down this number young people if you're
in between the ages of 18 to 39 i want
you to write down this number
this year i'm really focused on helping
young people
reach their goals get out of debt pay
off student loans go to college debt
free go to grad school debt free
i'm going to start building wealth we're
going to be teaching them how to really
purchase a home how to start a business
gonna be really doing a lot of things
and so i want you to text this number
asap six one five
nine three zero three four three one
again a number is six one five
nine three zero three four three one uh
this is the official line to communicate
directly with me
and my team uh so that we can help our
young people just get out of debt
avoid debt and start building true
wealth and when i say true wealth john
i'm talking about
true wealth we're not going to look like
we have money
we're really going to have money love it
we're not just going to drive a bmw
and be broke no we're going to have a
bmw and be wealthy
you know and so if that's you between
the ages of 18 39
i mean even if you're just older and you
just want to be a part of family as well
uh just give me a text 615-930-3431
direct line to myself and my team and
this year man
i'm sending out special things special
tips and tricks
i mean little nuggets to this uh this
family
and i'm releasing a podcast i ain't
gonna say win but they would be the
first person to know
because they're a part of family so you
mentioned generational wealth
yeah for so so many of us
yeah getting a paycheck is just so we
can
get some stuff eat rent transportation
go on a date or two but it's just to get
some stuff
what generational wealth means you know
when i think of generation and wealth i
think of my
kids kids you know for an example let's
let's step back and then you'll see what
i mean
uh we are in the world of fighting
against debt okay
for an example wells fargo two family
members last name not upset with them
rolls royce a car
family last name how was it that i i go
from the o'neill family when i was
younger
i would go to wells fargo a family
borrow money from them
on a credit card right or get a car loan
to go over to rolls royce for an example
to get a car
and then come back home to my family and
i'm broke
how's it that i work monday through
friday monday through friday
i i have this hard labor but i have no
fruit of my labor somebody else gets the
fruit of my heart labor
and so generational wealth for me is i'm
going to put in hard work
but i'm also going to put in hard work
so my kids can have a fruit of my labor
so my grandkids can have the fruit of my
labor so my grandkids grandkids will
know
my last name because of my hard labor
because i was a good steward
i was wise and i was thinking about them
not just thinking about how do i impress
some lady one of my biggest fear i told
this to my therapist
um um probably like two years ago she
said why are you so hungry about being
debt free like why you so hungry about
this message
it's because i watched my mom tell me no
on certain things that she should have
told me yes on
and i said i refuse to tell my wife no
when i should have told my girlfriend no
hmm i'm gonna tell my wife yes because i
told i
told them no a lot a lot of people get
upset at me now because i'll tell the
young lady
you know i'm not taking you out to no
500 restaurant you know what i'm saying
but i'll take my wife to a thousand
dollar restaurant you know
but i'm gonna make the right move so to
me generational wealth
is about thinking bigger than myself
it's about thinking about
my kids kids kids and that's what we're
doing here at ao we're building true
wealth
we're thinking about our last name we're
starting businesses we're avoiding debt
and we're really just switching our
mindset and looking at things
differently
a lot of people think that i want them
to drive
horrible cars no you're looking at me
when you said that well
you drive you drive a good car i don't
but it's cool it's it's but it's cool
for you it gets me where i need to go
that's it
and i want you to do what you want to do
there we go but you know i'ma drive the
car i want to drive
and i tell people that people say oh
that's not a dave ramsey car but what's
a dave ramsey car
a dave ramsey car is one that is debt
free got a fully funded emergency fund
he's fully investing and he's on his
mission that's a dave ramsey car
your car's a dave ramsey car mine is 99
george is a dave ramsey car is paid for
that's right and you got money in the
bank fair enough you know but see
me i don't like hunting you like hunting
right so you spend your money over there
right so i mean that's good you know i
ain't mad at you but at the end of the
day we're asking people
to do this one hard thing what is that
plant seeds and tend the soil of a tree
that you were never going to eat the
fruit from
right yeah and or you may get some yeah
but
i'm asking you to turn around and face
down your
your past face down
the the thoughts the the images all the
stuff
yeah and then turn around and choose
them will be different yeah so that
yeah those coming after me are going to
be able to eat that tree
so i bought like a few acres of land
cash
um last year and i
will never see the benefit from that
land
it will go to my kids there you go
that's something that my parents can't
do for me today
i could have spent that money and bought
a better car i could have spent that
money i could have used that money and
did something else that benefited me
right but i'm like no
i i want to i really want to build
true wealth i want to say that i have a
portfolio
and when i die i came into this world
crying
and i'ma leave this world smiling
because i came in here
crying i'ma look up at my wife and i'ma
see her and i'm seeing my kids
and i'm smiling because i know i'm
leaving them with wealth with joy with
peace
with freedom not stress and that is one
thing that i'm really trying to teach to
these young people like hey
we can have life we can enjoy life we
can have what we want
but are we really thinking about past us
the average person is going to leave
their families when they pass with bills
and benefits
not wealth not freedom not joy
and i refuse to be on this side and so
that's why
if you are between the ages of 18 and 39
i gotta stress this again
if you want to be serious about this
mission i want you to text 615-3930-3431
again at 615-930-3431
tell your friends come join the movement
because it's time for us young people to
change our mindset
and really start going after true wealth
and if you want to go
into 2021 on a high
join us next tuesday night january 12th
at 7 pm for our
free reset live stream event to
kickstart your money goals for 2021
that's any age anybody any group a
hundred thousand people plus have
already signed up for this
yeah it's out of control it's gonna be
chris hogan dave
rachel cruz craig rochelle they're going
to give you the motivation and guidance
you need to hit reset button and say
goodbye to stress for good
text reset to 33789
or you can sign up at daveramsey.com
reset that's reset to three three seven
eight nine daveramsey.com
reset we're gonna start living
differently
starting now this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
dalony joined here by ramsey personality
anthony o'neil and we are taking your
calls
about your life your money triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to aj in
indianapolis aj what's going on how can
we help
hey guys i really appreciate you taking
time to help me today
oh man thank you for taking time to call
in what can we do to help
yeah so i just changed to careers which
was a blessing
and now we have a very variable income
meaning it can be you know anywhere from
three to five hundred dollars less than
what we need
uh to live on each month all the way up
to you know two to three thousand
dollars more
so just wondering how do we best budget
that
like um yeah just looking for tips
on on that oh man such a great question
man you know and
both uh john and i's income fluctuates
every single month okay so we we are
very familiar
uh with this and we see it as well
here's something that i do from a
practical uh
standpoint is i actually do the budget
um
off of the last three months average so
let's say for an example
um if i go back to the first quarter of
this year uh it says say if we was in
let's say our april
january march april we're in april i'm
gonna look at what was my average over
the last three months
and whatever that average is that's the
lowest month i'm actually going to make
that
my budget for the previous month now
here's the thing that you're going to
have to really do is to
pretty much make your living expenses
off of
that average so your income not your
income but your living expenses need to
be less than 25
of that low point not your high point
and let's just say for example you do
bring in an extra two thousand dollars
but you know for example
like for me my summer months are
extremely low
okay so july and august for me are my
lowest months ever
so throughout the first six months i'm
actually
pocketing money to go towards my june
july and august uh budget
okay so if i'm making two thousand
dollars more for an example
i'ma set aside at least 1500 of that to
go towards
my very low months so when you get extra
your thing is you're still living off of
that that average
okay and you're pocketing the rest for
your low months
does that does that make sense yeah no
that makes a lot of sense
and to provide a little background we we
are on baby step two
okay um we're uh we're about seven
thousand away from being out
out of that okay um and so would you
suggest
like keeping a three-month buffer and
then whatever
else is extra throwing at the debt or
how does that work
so here's what i'm going to suggest i'm
going to suggest that if you know for an
example this is supe
easy math let's say for an example you
need 5 000
to live every single month but then you
know for an example in july you're only
going to make
2 500. so this means let's say if you
make an extra
seven thousand dollars um this month yes
i want you to put that extra two grand
in the savings account because that's
what you need to live off of
the next month now let's say for an
example you make an
extra five grand no put the two grand
aside for your low month and then you
put the rest of that money
towards your debt because what i don't
want you to do is have
an extra money you put it all towards
that then you get to your low months
that you already know you're gonna have
and then you have no income to go
towards uh that month
so yes budget be wise but any extra
go ahead and add that uh to your your
debt
perfect and aji i tend to lean a little
more
scarcity mindset so i and i don't i
don't like to live that way
from a relationship or mental health
standpoint but i like to budget for my
lowest possible month
absolutely and that's where i live
against and that way anything i know
coming in is always going to be gravy on
top
and so we my wife and i said here's what
we
the lowest it's going to be this month
let's budget against that and anything
above that
then we've got our savings and payoff
priorities
right there in line right great question
man let's go to vanessa
in utah vanessa how's it going
good thank you so much for taking my
call you betcha how can we help
um so i am a full-time student
i work full-time and i just had a baby
and now i'm
basically a full-time mom all the time
now and
that kind of let a fire under my butt on
getting on top of my finances i've never
really budgeted before
me and my husband decided that we want
better for our family in the future and
long-lasting wealth like you guys were
talking about earlier
um so i just had a conversation with my
parents the other day that they're
being very gracious and they're helping
me pay for student loans
i have about 33 000 in student loans i
have a year and a half left
by the time i'm done in my well when i
start my career i'll be making
80 000 a year and they're giving me 400
a month to go towards whatever like we
need
but it's like intended for helping with
schooling that they had promised before
and weren't able to help
in prior years and i have a car loan of
about twelve hundred dollars um
and so i'm wondering if it would be
smarter to
put that money and pay off the car
faster or
do i put that towards the student loans
i'm gonna take that money and add it all
towards your debt snowball so
what's the lowest thing that you have
right now in debt
um it would be probably my credit card
okay which i just pay off every month
and then
um the thing is i'm like not very
financially
smart i guess in educated and so i don't
know like if my student
loans like i can see they're broken up
by
each specific loan but i know that when
you graduate it's all kind of just one
big box fund so i'm not really sure
how that works um so then there's like
you know 3 500
loan and twenty five hundred dollar loan
and this and that and then it adds up
that's that's up
yeah so vanessa one of the things that
we teach here is the debt snowballs so
number one
uh i'm not gonna you know hammer this
down your throat today but you already
know what i'm about to say you gotta cut
up the credit card
i get the idea of paying off every
single month but you know what i teach
there so that's that
after that i want you to line up all
your debt from smallest to largest so i
want you to break down your student
loans
uh a loan b loan c loan d loan and
attack it that way
so make all your minimum payments you
know on each one and then the extra that
you have left over from the 400
of your mama giving you or from your
income put that towards the smallest
loan
work it the exact same way so i'm not
saying hey just put
one towards the lump sum of a loan no
knock out one loan
a loan b loan c loan d loan
and then go from there but how much is
your car worth
um i'm not really sure i bought it at 22
000.
okay all right how much um when did you
buy it
uh 2017. 2017. so you should be right
around like 15 16 and probably what kind
of car is it
it's a crv crv okay cool so it should be
worth right around 13
in um and so i would definitely attack
that i mean once you get a job
i would definitely definitely attack
that your parents are taking good care
of you so that's a good thing
okay and vanessa thank you so much
vanessa thank you full-time student
full-time employee now you're a mom
you grew a human yeah all this in 2020.
i don't ever want you to say the words
i'm not that smart ever again
okay okay thank you for you someone who
is is willing to grind and work hard and
be a person of
of high responsibility and character
integrity
this is this is an easy thing for you to
figure out okay
okay thank you so much put your head to
it put your mind to it put your heart to
it you're gonna be out of debt in no
time you're gonna be an extraordinary
mom that's that's awesome
yeah that's awesome i mean that's really
that's a lot i mean full-time
full-time student full-time employee and
a full-time mom she got
three full-time jobs i tell you what and
that being a full-time mom is like five
full-time jobs she's got nine full-time
she's got 17 full-time jobs right now
absolutely especially to a newborn baby
but there's nothing
that will get your fire going like
looking at another human being that is
totally helpless and dependent on you
saying
what's my legacy going to be mom what's
my legacy going to be dad
what's it going to look like right i
look forward to that day yeah yeah
i'ma cry you're going to cry when you
have a kid oh yeah
i'm just kidding i did too on both sides
are you trying to tell me he didn't cry
i cried on both of mine i still cry i
saw my son play in the snow this morning
all by himself
oh i started crying i'm not gonna cry
when i see him playing the snow i'm
gonna say clean that mess up
i wanna thank producer james childs and
associate producer kelly daniel
thank you for joining us we'll be back
this has been the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
and your money i am john deloney joined
here by best-selling author youtube
sensation
and instagram hero ramsay personality
mr anthony o'neill we are taking your
calls about your life
your relationships anything and
everything give us a shout
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five
five two two five or send your question
in at ramsey
show anthony how are we doing hey man
i'm doing great man it's a beautiful day
out here we got some beautiful people
out here in the audience and uh
just enjoying us this amazing day that's
fantastic all right let's go to max
in philadelphia pennsylvania max how are
we doing this afternoon
hey fellas how are you thanks for taking
the time you betcha how can we help
brother
yeah um so i wanna i've never really
done anything like
this before so i wanna make sure i ask
this in the best way possible
um i made a huge mistake in going to
boston university for school
um between bentley and bu
i took about 250 000 of student loans
for an education degree that i'm not
using i'm not teaching
um i'm working you know i'm looking at a
bank i'm lucky to be employed but uh
there are 207 000 of that is in default
um
my payment was supposed to be 2200 a
month uh
i make 50 a year i just simply don't
make enough
to make that kind of payment um
so i guess i'm wondering especially
during these circumstances where you
know i hear dave talk about being as
gazelle and trying to take this
and take care of this as quickly as
possible uh i was driving uber
i was you know i played piano part-time
and you know for the better part of the
year i guess it'll be a year next month
like
all of that has been completely
decimated and
who knows when it might come back um i
guess i will say on top of that like the
uber thing i got into a car accident a
few months ago and got a concussion so
cars go on for now too um so i guess
one what are these i mean in your
experience have you or have you heard
any stories about what these creditors
actually do
i i mean i'm paying them 400 a month but
obviously that's a drop in the bucket
um and it's kind of a nightmare scenario
yeah you're not making squandering
you're not making a dent in it at all
uh max yeah and right now uh you need a
bigger shovel
right okay okay um do we need to get
your income up
uh because you you're not going to be
able to pay it off
uh making 55 thousand dollars 58 000
a year we need to get your income up
right all right um especially with 400
of my payments so what what's your
career right now
i work at a bank in china all right what
did you go to school for
elementary education okay all right so
yeah
why they approved that you know 250 000
is beyond me
hey hold on hold on though max hold on
let's don't do that yeah okay
yeah yeah let's take full ownership of
where we're at okay
you signed it bro i mean and it's yeah
yeah you're normal
you know what i'm saying you're you're
normal i signed for student level i did
too
i mean we're not it was the stupidest
thing i've ever done well i mean
we've all done we all been there so
let's put that down and let's move on to
solving the problem now right
yeah so sounds good all right so you're
making 58 000
a year in the banking institution all
right you said you cannot drive for uber
what else can you do so you have an
education
um can you go home and tutor online
right now
especially within your age bracket max
you can you can jump online
and do some creative things to generate
some income
all right right now you need to step
back and and
have a game plan how are you going to
generate another 25 000
a year because check this out if you
could generate another 25 000
a year you can attack this debt and be
debt free within the next three to four
years uh because i'm going to show you
how to pretty much negotiate
i'm going to give you access to my book
destroy your student loan that i want so
when we hang up once you stay on the
line kelly's gonna send you that book
for free
on john and i it's really on me because
it's my book but i love john
i'm happy to take credit yeah yeah but
i'm gonna show you how to refi it
uh how to get it out of collections how
to refi it and how to come up with
creative ways to negotiate
some type of uh settlement offers within
this thing now you may not be able to
settle it i'm not saying you will be but
you
might be able to but the key thing for
you right now
is uh making your your shovel larger as
far as getting your income so that's
what we're going to do we're going to
give you two books
uh ashton i'm gonna give you two books
i'm gonna give you one book and then i'm
gonna tell you
you need to go listen to our good friend
ken coleman we call him the shovel guy
okay because he's going to show you how
to turn his 58 thousand dollars
and maybe turn it into a hundred
thousand dollars because he's a
pro at teaching people how to make more
money how to get into their sweet spot
so you have a shovel problem and then
from there you need to go ahead and get
gazelle intense and i'm gonna show you
how to take that shovel
and get out of debt you failed me
yeah yeah so we really can't lay out too
much for you right now but the key thing
is
you got to get on a clear budget you for
the next three to five years max you are
broke
okay you don't have time to you are you
single are you married
i'm actually getting married to december
you get married in december
um okay how much debt does she have
uh i as far as i know zero as far as you
know you ain't talking about
you know you're getting married have
that conversation today max
you you propose without norm certainly
doesn't doesn't have the uh
student loan issue that i do oh yeah
yeah but she may got she may have carlo
she may have so i mean yeah well no no
car alone
okay cool well just ask her you know ask
her do you have any debt
outside of a mortgage you know just just
but just ask her you know
and they say now that's now that just
brings up another thing right there
right you know you're gonna have two
incomes you have two incomes attacking
his debt
you can go out there and generate some
more what does she do for a living
uh she works for the uh the state of
jersey right now oh so she's making
pretty decent money now with some good
benefits
uh yeah they're doing all right i mean
she's only working one day a week
uh i i don't know something about them
not being able to distribute laptops for
last year
which is a little ridiculous but well
she's going into the office one day a
week but is she working from home
no i i mean i don't know what their team
came up with but
yeah basically they're going into the
office one day a week and that's it for
now until this kind of calms down i
it's beyond me i haven't all right so
hey max
about it hey max is something i'm
picking up in your soul a little bit
that just to cut through it okay in your
original question you asked us
what are the creditors really going to
do and behind that
is yeah this sense of you you feel
guilty that you signed a piece of paper
and that that waffles back and forth
between blaming the folks who let you
sign it which is fair
and feeling stupid and ashamed that you
did what you did
i want you to think of that guilt and
that shame as a big cinder block
you are not going to get anywhere in a
in a new marriage you're not going to
get anywhere towards paying down this
debt which brother you owe
until you put that cinder black cinder
block down
pick up a shovel two of them three of
them yes
you you got wiped out in 2020. it sucks
now you got a choice to make brother are
you gonna sit there and go what are they
really going to do they're going to come
get me
are you going to get back up be the be
the
the the husband that your new wife is
going to deserve
and need and that she is marrying into
and then brother go
pay off your debt stay on the line
anthony's going to give you his book
and you're going to call us back in the
year and we're going to show you you're
going to tell us how far you've wiped
this sucker down
because you're on it this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm dr john
deloney with my
friend and ramsey personality anthony
o'neal and we are taking your calls
about life
and money triple eight eight two five
five two two five
it's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
[Music]
twenty twenty is over and we are into
twenty twenty one
now the first five days we're looking
pretty sharp anthony and then we got off
the rails pretty quick
we all need a reset so i want you to
join us
next tuesday night january 12th at 7 pm
for our free reset live stream event to
kickstart your money goals
for 2021 this is free over a hundred
thousand people have already signed up
it's going to include chris hogan
rachel cruz dave ramsey and craig
rochelle
they're going to give you the motivation
and guidance you need to hit the reset
button and say goodbye to money stress
for good millions of you got hit
unawares you didn't see it coming we've
been telling you for years we don't say
i told you so on the show
but we told you so and then 2020 showed
up
hit reset for good text reset to 33789
now to sign up and take the first step
towards lasting financial peace or you
can sign up
at daveramsey.com reset
if you're in the oklahoma city area you
can join us live and in person
very limited limited seating obviously
with the right social distancing and
spacing
but you can be a part of the church
audience the tickets there are 20 bucks
and are available at daveramsey.com
events if there is even any left i have
no idea
number two here's a second thing you can
do ramsay plus you hear us talk about
all the time it's our step-by-step money
plan that will give you the
accountability and practical tips you
need to pay off your debt faster than
you can
on your own as we start 2021 we got a
challenge for you decide on a total
money reset this year
then start ramsey plus and commit to
working
like mad hard in the first 90 days
and watch as those small daily wins turn
into lifelong habits
so you never feel out of control with
money
again to start ramsay plus for free go
to daveramsey.com
reset all right let's go to
sunday in philadelphia sunday how are we
doing
i'm amazing how you guys doing amazing
as well
what can we do to help well i'm really
calling because
i've been with my fiance for a long
while now
we we've been together for about 10
years it's finally taken me
10 years to open up and say okay i'm
ready
i'm ready to put our money together i'm
ready to to go in hard on this
and i mean finally i'm a fiance so now i
feel pretty safe
but um with that being said
i'm i'm scared that he's not going to
follow through i listen to dave ramsey
all the time
he listened to it but he doesn't always
go in what should i do
[Laughter]
there's a lot here i was about to say
something then i thought i'm not going
to say anything and let anthony and he
just turn and look directly at me
so you should be scared
okay yes
ten years that's a decade right
yes and suddenly you you feel like
you're going to feel safe because
you got a ring on your finger after a
decade
right yes and three presidents ago how
about that
so thank you a long time ago
and it felt good for a few days you got
that ring finally
and then your your consciousness kicked
back in
your frontal lobe came back online and
you thought
oh man this is the same guy that either
i or he
or we have not felt in sync with for a
decade enough to get married
right so you should your body's alarm
systems are going off and they should be
right is that fair yes
am i telling you anything that you don't
already know
yes no i don't know and you know
sunday i'm just telling you the truth i
i'm gonna i'm gonna turn over anthony
here
you're not in a position to be joining
money up together right now
you're not safe until you are married
you're not safe until you've sat down
and had full conversations and if you
have some priorities
and your priorities right now according
to your language is being
safe that's baseline for a marriage and
after a decade with somebody if you
don't feel safe you guys need to have
different conversations
you need to be having deeper
conversations probably at this point
with a
with a therapist with a pastor in your
community that you can be open and
honest with because you're going in
hedging your bets
on a marriage and it's not going to work
and you should not not
not be joining money with a 10-year
boyfriend
who you know is not all into
how long have i been engaged sunday
just about a year when's when you are
getting married
well can i just blame it on the pandemic
no
no no no no you go get married at the
courthouse no sunday now you know you
can't come in here and talk with ao and
jd like that
you know what i'm saying maybe dave but
not with us so what are y'all getting
married
what's the date we know it's this year
what's the day oh my don't have a game
i'll tell you what it is all right
20 32. what's another what's another 10
years why not
no i'm not gonna do better sunday listen
um you already know you don't need to be
combining your your finances with a
potential husband
okay um you're not you're not in a safe
place but i do know
ladies that is an emotion emotional
security is very important and i
understand that
but a ring on your finger as
a fiance is not the emotional security
all right
so what i'm telling you is set the date
y'all go to the courthouse this weekend
go to the courthouse tomorrow go ahead
and become husband and wife
and together y'all work a game plan but
until then
until you all are legally married
and i don't know about pennsylvania but
y'all may be already
uh pretty much married because of common
law and common law
um but i mean i'm talking about within
the eyesight of
god i mean that's just my faith in the
christian faith i want y'all to go ahead
and get legally married and have a plan
together
stop do y'all live together
yes yeah so you're already giving him
wife benefits and and he can leave you
tomorrow
okay and so for me right now what you
need to do is say you know what babe
let's go get married let's do this
we've been together for 10 years do you
all have kids together
yes we have a daughter yeah so i don't
know what what we're planning on
okay uh what what what's going on here
sunday you have kids together
okay so you're already doing husband and
wife things you bout to combine your
money you live in the same place you're
paying all the bills together
just go ahead and get married don't
blame it on covet don't blame it on no
one else
and then once kobe gets over then you
can have a huge celebration
but i firmly do believe that if you do
it in a healthy
and the right way blessings follow that
the security that that you desire the
emotional security
that you desire the blessings that you
desire will come
once you just get married you're already
doing
everything tonight
go get married but i'll but i'll add
this i want to add this
if you only want to get married when you
feel safe
you have your answer and you know that
right
right who's who's the reason we're being
held up here
it's both of us it's it's it's okay i
was about to say
yeah i'm about to say she gonna hold me
up i'll tell you that right now
well look at here girl it's been 10
years baby what are we going to do so we
can tell
it's it's on both of them right but if
you go get married what i'm saying here
is if
sunday if you go get married tomorrow
and and
you're unable to have hard conversations
with someone you've been with
for a decade that you have a child with
that's not just going to solve itself on
monday
right right yeah
i'm confused to why it sounds like
they're both scared of commitment
because they're already doing
every everything thing else so it sounds
like i am scared
to legally say this is the rest of my
life because
i'm already doing everything and what i
want to get to is why are you still
scared after 10 years
that's what i yes that's yes yes so
sunday
you got to address those hard hard
questions yeah
and then if you come to a place where
you say i'm he's my guy
like kanthi said you're already doing it
you're already there
[Music]
then you come come back we're going to
give you ramsay plus you and him your
new husband you're going to go through
it together
you're going to learn these lessons
together you're going to dream and
create a vision together
it's never too late to start then after
10 years of running in place then you're
gonna be ready to rock and roll
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping and a guaranteed
perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm dr john
dolone joined here by
my good friend anthony o'neal we are
taking your calls on life and money at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five
let's go to cara in lubbock texas kara
how are we doing
good how are you dr dean good good good
how can we help
hey um quick question so
um i am currently a full-time student
and finishing my
clinical social work degree uh my
master's degree and
so i haven't been employed in a year so
i also we're in baby step two so we're
not contributing to our
um to our retirement right now anyway
but when i left my full-time job i also
left
my 401k and i haven't gotten a new job
so i don't have like another 401k to
to transfer that to so i was wondering
do i just let it sit where it's at
since we're not contributing anyway and
then when i get a new job transfer that
or should it
open one by myself right now such a
great question kara
uh we never never never advise you to
switch it to a 401k
i mean to another 401k what i want you
to do is switch that over
get on the phone with the financial
advisor and switch it over to a roth ira
okay um you can get on the phone if you
go to uh anthony.com for
experts or daveramsey.com you can find a
financial advisor or smartvestor pro
that will help you move your 401k
over to a an ira i would suggest moving
over to a roth ira so it can grow and
you know to pay taxes on it moving
forward but
do that asap so when you get off the
phone with me go over to my website
anthonynow.com force
experts look for smart investor pro and
just tell them hey i have a 401k and i
would love to switch it over from there
um and i know you don't have a job right
now but i would recommend
cara how much debt do you have right now
um it's actually all student loans and
it's mine
we've paid off about 65 000 since last
september
way to go um and you said we so you're
married um
yes me and my husband all right okay um
and he's the sole provider of our
household so and he makes
um without felt like bonuses and stuff
um he probably brings in about 85 to 90
and 90 a year cool great especially in
texas that's good money
out there y'all living good yeah well
we're in the permian basin i'm sure john
knows where that is you betcha yeah yeah
and what industry that is yep yes yes
so that's good that's good i would
definitely recommend that how much that
are you all combined
uh total income in the house all we have
left is my student loans and i
was one of those people oh god ao i wish
i would have met you so
long ago yeah yeah um we all do care
about
take out student loans yes i'm the one
that took out those student loans to
support my lifestyle
and go to school and get the things that
i wanted you know
um so i think the last time i checked
i'm like 126
000 in debt okay cool and you're in
school right now
i think you you said that right yes i
actually just made my first
cash payment to tuition in my life okay
cool and so you're not borrowing any
money right
no i paid for i paid for this semester
that starts
in a couple of days all cash and it was
my first
time to ever do that in my life and it
hurts it hurts doesn't it
hey can i ask you can i ask you this
question would you have gotten a
master's degree after feeling how much
that hurts to make that cash payment
if you had had to pay in cash would you
have gone to school when you did or
would you have held off
oh absolutely i have a desire to help
people um
i'm getting my master's in clinical
social work right now
yeah so i would have i would have saved
it up and maybe put it off a few more
years so i could have paid cash but
there you go yeah you know we all live
and learn the hard way
man you're telling me and here's the
only thing to our recommend cara
um and we can go to next call um is
i get it that your husband's a
breadwinner um and i also get that
you're back in school full-time
but figure out a way of how you can
generate is maybe an extra two grand a
grand two grand a month
you know from working from home how can
you do something online how can you
maybe
uh deliver some groceries on your off
time something that doesn't require
you know a full workload but something
that you can do from online and so i
would recommend you looking into maybe
christy wright's book business boutique
she teaches people how to turn their
hobbies into passion and
it's a great book where you can generate
you know extra grand that can go towards
your student loans that's twelve
thousand dollars extra uh that can help
you out so i would definitely look into
how can you contribute a little bit so
that way uh
your husband's not carrying too much of
the load all right let's go to christina
in orlando florida christina what's
going on
hi guys thank you for taking my call
hopefully well
um i just have a quick question about
i want to try to invest i i'm 40
30 42 i'm an rn and i make about a
little under 90 grand a year
um i have three children i'm a single
mother and i just
my car's paid off i have no student
loans no credit card debt
i just bought a house in february and i
wonder
if i should but i have no savings that's
my only downfall
i don't i spend a lot on bills and
student
tuition for the kids things like that um
so i wondered if i should really start
putting more money into savings or
paying off my house
yeah yeah yeah and i know you said did
you say you were 42 or 32 i
can't remember i'm gonna be 42. oh you
you're young lady you're a young lady
thank you yes ma'am uh yes
i want you to stack up that emergency
fund especially with children
all right and so i want you to get on a
very
detailed budget uh and we call that
every dollar budget and i want you to
miss out every single thing
okay and then what i want you to do is
look at that budget and see
what can you cut what can go in half
because i want you to get that three to
six months and to be honest
i tell single mothers to get to to aim
for that six months
because if you're by yourself and single
three months is great but what you
having kids
you you need a little bit more cushion
um especially as a single mother
and so i'm going to say take that car
payment that you had
put it over there into the savings don't
worry about your house right now make
the minimum payment on your house
but then you need to get on a very
detailed budget every dollar
okay if you go to uh daveramsey.com
forward slash hope right now
uh you can get every dollar for free for
like 14 days i think i i can't remember
the exact terms
uh kelly or james if y'all could tell me
if i'm right on that but i know it's
free for either seven or 14 days
if you go over there right now and just
list out that
um well every dollar is free but the the
the time
yeah the premium version is what you can
get for 14 days for free
but the bottom line is i want you to
budget so let's say for example you got
apple music spotify
uh you can cut spotify let's say we have
netflix hulu disney plus for your kids
uh you can cut two of those you can
generate an extra fifty dollars just
from looking at your budget sometimes
if you just really sit down and just
list it out so
you're in a good place you're in a
healthy place you are debt free
now let's go ahead and make sure that we
generate some income to where we can get
a fully funded emergency fund to prevent
you
from going back into debt but
and check that out i want you to get
every dollar it is our free tool
um but i i do want you to connect that
to your checking account
so that way you can see what's going in
what's going out and you can stay on top
of your money okay
hey christine can we geek out for a
second
i'm sorry can i can we geek out for a
second
yes please uh you're an rn you said
a registered nurse yeah okay so what's
your what's your typical patient load
well actually i don't i don't do patient
direct care i am a nurse case manager so
everything i do is
telephonic and i actually work from home
that was a pandemic but before that
i was working three days a week from
home and in two days from the office
very cool patient care yeah that's a
great setup okay
so um you know this
in other forms and i'm confident that
you know this if you sat down and
thought about it
but there is a physiological consequence
to feeling unsafe right absolutely there
is a
cortisol and an adrenaline consequence
to waking up with your heart racing a
little bit faster right
when you wake up with no emergency fund
and three kids no net
every day you are choosing to put
another cigarette in your mouth
take an extra drink think of it that way
and get intense about an emergency fund
you will find yourself sleeping laughing
harder
and you'll find this magic magic place
called
peace you got it christina
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]
so
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
dalony joined here by
ramsey personality and best-selling
author mr anthony o'neill
we are taking your calls on life and
money triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to janelle in
miami florida
janelle what's going on hey how you guys
doing
good deal how are you pretty good pretty
good
um i have a quick question for you
regarding buying a home
okay go for it my husband and i we've
been renting for about seven years now
and we just had our first child last
june
and we're in a one bedroom apartment but
we need more space yes
i've been speaking to different people
and some people are telling me that
buying a home is an investment
some are saying that buying a home is um
is debt
and so i just want to kind of get your
take on your first time home buyer
yeah you know janelle both of the people
who are telling you that information
buying a home is investment
true buying home buying a home is debt
true okay so those are true
two true statements that they have given
you but let's
let's apply this to your life where are
you all at
as a couple as far as in income what's
your laws combined income household
income
um it's about 56 60 000.
okay so yeah 60 000 of combined income
what's your
total amount of debt right now
about 80 80 000 in debt and what is what
kind of debt is that
um for me it's student loans car
personal loan hospital bills and then
for him
a student loans and hospital bills okay
all right cool and so should you buy a
house
now the respectful answer is no
should you look into moving and maybe
get you a bigger
apartment or maybe a town home that you
can rent
yes um how do you janelle if you don't
mind me asking
26. cool great um
here's what i want to here's what i want
to tell you i'm a 36 year old guy i just
purchased my first home and i was 31
32 yeah so 32 when i was 32 years old
i purchased my very first home all right
and i was making good money
at by the time i was like 27 28.
um never let someone tell you that
your mortgage payment is going to be
cheaper than your rent payment
because your house will not be cheaper
than your apartment
okay so yes the mortgage payment will be
cheaper than your rent
payment some a lot of times
but your house will not be cheaper
than your apartment i don't want you to
rush
you have enough time janelle you have
enough time
to pay off your debt secure a fully
funded emergency fund
and then when you move into your house
you can move into maybe your dream
home if you follow what i teach
especially
uh to us millennials all right and so
i'm gonna say respectfully no
now is not a good time for you to uh
purchase a home
do i believe that you should look into
possibly
getting a two bedroom apartment or maybe
even consider getting a nice little
two two bedroom uh town home with a
garage in it
and just start working your way up in
that process absolutely
but janelle if you rock with me and if
you listen to what i teach you
i guarantee you by the time you turn 27
uh you will be in a much better place
and you'll be able to purchase and
build you a home not just buy any kind
of house
all right yeah so can i ask you a
question
we'll go ahead sure i was going to say i
want you to change your po
pronoun problem okay when anthony how
much asked you how much debt you had
you listed your debt and then you listed
his debt
it's y'all's debt yeah okay
you and and your husband are in this
together
you are parents of a beautiful little
baby y'all are working together
to get out of debt together to be great
parents together to buy a home
and so i want you guys to sit down and
do this together okay
you got another question follow up go
for it yes
um well question to comment comment i'm
27. i keep forgetting my age
um but needless to say just add one more
year for us for our use of division
um but when you say that the house will
cost
more than the apartment um what do you
mean by that and
i hear what you're saying with the
mortgage are you saying like the repairs
and stuff that come with the house
the expense of the house so for an
example your water bill is going to go
up from a one bedroom to a three bedroom
house
you're not going to buy a two-bedroom
house i remember uh janelle when i
left my um one-bedroom apartment and i
built my house
my electricity bill was maybe about like
58 dollars a month for my light bill
right
then when i built this 3 000 big
beautiful square foot home
um my electricity bill went from 58
to guess how much 413 dollars because i
went from
doing power to a 5 600 square foot
apartment
uh to now 3 000 two level
uh place and so it's not just
electricity you talk about electricity
when you get a house you gotta you gotta
have
maintain the grass that means you gotta
water the grass you gotta
saw the grass or or do whatever you want
to do there's so many different things
and if something goes wrong with the
house and if you don't have an emergency
fund
and then how are you going to fix it and
so i get it yes buying a home is a great
investment but here's what i'm trying to
prevent you from doing
is going into something that you
consider it to be a dream and then you
wake up a year from now it turned into a
nightmare
all right so janelle i want you to text
me i want you to be a part of my family
i'm going to help you out i want you to
text this number
three zero 615-930-3 four three one
again at six one five
nine three zero three four three one i'm
helping
young people uh in that age bracket
every single day
get out of debt build wealth go but
start a business
go build uh build homes or buy homes buy
the dream cars
so text that number uh today you'll be a
part of family my team and i are going
to keep you up to date and we're going
to help you accomplish your dreams i
promise you that much
and anything along those lines i'm
living it
i bought a house recently we had it
beautiful
top to bottom inspector a font did a
fine job
so far i've had to repair the driveway
yeah got to get a new roof
i got a right i got i got it gotta had
to get a new mower how did
those things add up and when i was
renting before
man i didn't think of any of that stuff
right because i just made a phone call
and somebody else came out and fixed it
yeah
and so yeah the the rent versus the the
ownership man
it never plays out mathematically like
that right it really doesn't
and what i try to tell especially young
people this generation wants to own
like they i get it and i love that
they're thinking about
ownership but no one's honestly taking
the time and teaching them hey
okay i want you to own but here's how
you do it
what's the cost of ownership right yeah
you know i i am so grateful that before
i purchase a home
i came here because listening to dave
listening to chris hogan
and watching how they they move things
and see and seeing how they think about
things it's like oh i'm not ready yet
because you see when you get into the
home you're going to want new furniture
right and then nine times out of ten
you're gonna go finance the furniture
so i'm like no when i get into the home
i want to pay cash
for all of my furniture and it felt so
good to walk into the store
i have a budget and i want that i want
this yeah i want that and i'm sleeping
on a paid for bed
i'm sitting on a paid for couch you know
i'm pushing it paid for a lawnmower
you know i paid cash for the landscaping
of my house and here's the thing i'm
gonna be real
i'm gonna be real with y'all today we
got about two more minutes let's be real
with y'all
i had a beautiful home i sold it uh
because i moved downtown in asheville
tennessee
but i said you know i want something
beautiful so what i did is
i waited two extra years because i
wanted
something i really really liked
and i'm telling you it felt good yeah
people said anthony
you're wasting money you know what no no
no no because i'm going to skip over all
the drama that you're going to go
through
and i'm going to do it right and it was
the best feeling for those four years
living in that house
pulling into this big old house with
beautiful lights all over it in
and beautiful grass because i did it
right i did exactly what we teach and it
felt good to wake up on every single
month
and all i had to worry about was my
mortgage payment but when something did
go wrong with my house
it just became an inconvenience it was
annoying it wasn't a shape shifter right
no because i had the money in my account
right but so i'm like that's what i'm
teaching this generation
you want to get this car great let me
show you how to get it you you want to
start this business
great let me show you how to get it you
want to build this house you want to go
into this house
great let me show you how to do it but
there's a process right and that process
you know and we call it financial
freedom for a reason yeah because you
get to sleep at night
man i love it i'm trying to tell y'all
all right that's another hour in the
books this has
been the dave ramsey show i want to
thank producer james childs and
associate producer kelly daniel
be well be kind pay your bills this has
been
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from their dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
and your money i am dr john dolone
joined here by my good friend anthony
o'neill
ramsey personality and best selling
author youtube sensation and we are
taking your calls about your life
and your five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five let's go to joe in
farmington minnesota
joe how's it going i'm doing good how
are you
outstanding good man how can we help
so my wife and i are
we just looked over all our financials
and we're just wondering
how do we get even get started with our
emergency fund and
moving into baby step two oh man that's
a
that's a good question i love these kind
of questions joe so
talk to me why is it difficult for you
to get into baby step one
uh with which is a thousand dollar
emergency fund
uh it i for me at least it just seems
like
i'm living paycheck to paycheck for sure
i mean
um i'm a trucker and my wife is a police
officer so i mean we make
okay money but what's okay ready joe how
much money do you all make um
together yes about 120 130
and you're telling me you can't come up
with a thousand dollars joe
and the the part i'm running into is
that we're
i have about ten thousand dollars in
credit card debt
together we're about 17 000 in credit
card debt and we just got
new cars and i'm not making excuses i've
made stupid money decisions this past
year for sure
and beyond that as well okay
it just seems like my debt payments are
so
big i don't even know where to start
saving up that thousand dollars
okay well that's a good question when's
the last time you did a budget
okay yeah when's the last time you did
one have you done what
uh we well we just downloaded the
every dollar app last night i haven't
looked through it yet but we just
downloaded it all right so here's
let me let me give you some practical
things and some some practical facts joe
all right the average couple um the
average household income is right around
58
000 a year okay i want you to really
understand that 58
000 is an average household income
in america you're making double of that
double plus
okay that's one number two what's the
very first thing you have to do
when it comes to how do we start getting
better with our finances
take debt off of the table
okay so this means stop swiping your
credit card
stop financing things stop adding things
to
uh the debt pile take it completely off
the table here's number three okay
here's number three
and this has nothing to do with money
because when i get to the practical
money stuff
um it's simple it's easy it's what we
teach the seven baby steps but what i'm
hearing from you is
i haven't i haven't heard the gut
conviction from you and here's something
that i want you and your wife to do
tonight
okay are are you are you gonna go home
tonight with your wife are you out there
trucking right now i am going to be home
with my wife tonight yes cool great do
y'all have any kids
we do not okay cool great uh you love
your wife
very much okay you took time on that
okay she loves you i'm sure of it
uh i want you to order some pizza
tonight
i want you to cut off your cell phone
cut off youtube and i want you to look
your wife
in her face and say hey why do we want
to get out of debt
and before you ask your wife that i want
you to be thinking about that from the
time you hang up from us
to the time you ask your wife that
i want you to be so convicted ask
yourself
why five times when my good friends
pastor brian bullock says
the the five wives like when you answer
the question the first time go deeper or
if you say well i want to get out of um
i want to get out of debt well why do
you want to get a debt well i want to
get a debt so i can purchase a home well
why do you want to purchase a home
well i want to purchase a home so i can
have a you know a nice home for my kids
why do you want to have a nice home for
your kids like go deep
because here's the thing your why in
life to change your finances need to
make you quiet
if your why does it make you cry then
the price of commitment
will make you cry so i need you
and your wife to have a gut why a why
that gets you too
emotional so when you think about why
you want to go out on this journey
it makes you to get very emotional when
you get that gut why
i promise you finding a thousand dollars
for babysit number one
will be easy you'll have it within the
next two weeks
but right now there's no real reason why
you want to get out of debt there's no
real reason why you want a thousand
dollars
so it's easy for you be like i don't
know how to do it a little paycheck to
the paycheck no
let me tell you my why joe and it makes
me cry and i ain't gonna cry on the dave
ramsey show
because it's a dave ramsey show now my
show i'll cry okay
but my why is i watch my mom and dad
struggle we never went to disney world i
had to put
socks on the bottom of my shoes because
we couldn't afford to buy new shoes
we never went family vacations i don't
have family pictures of
me and my family i refuse to be that man
from my family
i refuse to tell my kids hey put
put tape on the bottom of your shoes
because i can't afford to buy you new
stuff no
i refuse to be the guy to tell my wife
we can't go on a family vacation
because we're living above our means and
when i think about that that gets me
emotional
that's why i'm so passionate about this
message what is that why it's gonna get
you passionate
of getting a thousand dollars getting
out of debt when you do that
the seven baby steps that we teach will
become easy
i promise you and joe from this point
forward
there is no more hers in mind
there is ours she doesn't have a credit
card and you don't have a credit card
and she doesn't have a car
payment and you don't have a car payment
you all have a car payment
y'all are in this for the long haul
you're in this together
you're gonna rise and fall together and
so i want you to after you have this
exercise with anthony
it's a beautiful moment it should be
hard it should be uncomfortable you
should probably have conversations that
you all should have had a long time ago
that you
have never had before i want you to
start thinking about what the budget's
going to look like
once you go to daveramsey.com you can
download the budget worksheet
and you can begin to start to put some
some meat and flesh around the bones of
why are we doing this who are we going
to be what we're going to be yeah right
yeah
and joe if you haven't uh taken
financial peace university yet
i want you to go to daveramsey.com and i
want you to take ramsey um
sign up for ramsay plus i did look it's
it's a 14-day free trial right now so
that's daveramsey.com forward slash
reset um and after you have the talk
tonight i want you to spend the next
nine days watching those videos with
your
wife okay and together you all are gonna
change you're gonna reset as a matter of
fact
you need to watch the event with dave
with hogan with rachel
and with craig rochelle you need to
spend these next seven days resetting
your thought process
coming up with your why getting
emotional and
you should be crying with your wife
tonight telling her baby we're gonna
change today
you make a hundred and twenty hundred
and thirty thousand dollars
imagine you don't owe anybody anything
at the end of every month
you're trying to figure out who to give
to who you can bless
your kid's gonna walk into a debt-free
life
but only you can turn that around
this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there plus they
offer
unbelievable financial benefits secure
your future today
visit nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
it's here it's here rachel cruz's brand
new book
know yourself no your money is out now
and this book
is a game changer in this book our good
friend rachel cruz will walk you through
the seven
money tendencies we all have and how
understanding yours
can help you reset your priorities and
win with money in 2021
join rachel cruz at her virtual launch
party actually she already had that one
but we're going to join her
at the live stream reset event next
tuesday night january 12th at 7 pm
it is going to be with chris hogan
rachel cruz craig rochelle
and dave ramsey they're going to give
you the motivation and guidance you need
to hit the reset button
and say goodbye say goodbye to the money
stress
for good text reset to 33789
that's reset 33789 or go to the online
store today
daveramsey.com and get your copy of know
yourself know your money
text reset seven eight nine grab the
book get ready to rock and roll
it's 20 21 start with a new book a new
event get your head right get your
family right let's get this thing going
you know what rachel asked a good
question in a book that convicted me
very well
okay and her and i talked about that on
my show what's up
she said do you make a purchase she said
if no one
saw the purchase would you still want it
do you buy something out of status
or out of safety and when she asked me
that question
i was convicted because i answered the
question
honestly saying there are 50 of my
purchases
that if no one ever saw them i would
have never bought it
really honestly wow and so one and two
half huh half i'm just being real yeah
i'm just being transparent yeah
people just like how can anthony how
what what no i'm being real
absolutely you know and so i want to
encourage you to get rachel's book
uh because she she's going to set you up
and she's
very raw and authentic in this book too
i think this is rachel's best book i'm
just going to be real
i love all of our other books i've read
all of them but i think this one right
here she gets to the gut
of why we make decisions with our
purchases
and when she when i read that in her
book i told her i need you on my show
because you you hit my gut and i love
how she breaks it down saying hey if
you're buying out of status
that's okay but at least you know it and
make sure you have the budget for it
but if you're purchasing things and not
purchasing purchasing things because of
safety
well hey that's okay too but wait a
minute there are some flaws in this side
too that's right
and so i love how rachel just really
breaks down this book
and this book is for someone all the way
down to 15
all the way up to 99. like she's really
really really teaching some very solid
steps and stuff in this so
i just want to say that because well and
i want to follow up yeah after talking
with
couples and couples and couples and
family members
she does a great job of drilling down
how come i get so fired up in my i did
my heart starts racing i get raging
when my wife asks about money or how
come every time my husband rolls his
eyes at a budget
i just get real quiet or i go off the
handle and she walks you
all the way back to where some of these
seeds were planted about money
in your childhood and then you get
married you start
dating whatever and you play these
scripts over and over and over again
and she helps you go oh man i'm just
playing a record that got
a cd that got you know plugged into me
when i was a child i don't have to keep
living like this but i got to
acknowledge that i'm on a track right
yes
and she does a great job of helping
people unwind why they do what they do
when it comes to money
like you and i talked about in a call
earlier um i have more of a scarcity
mindset you've got more of a planning
mindset right
more future oriented that comes from my
childhood yours comes from your
childhood
and they literally come from there right
and there's nothing wrong with either
side
but you gotta acknowledge it acknowledge
it and you gotta know the flaws
that's right you know you have to know
uh the flaws
on whatever whatever you're part of
because i'm trying to say this in the
correct way
um whatever side you're on
there's nothing wrong with it just
acknowledge the flaws
of whatever you decide to be on so i
care you know
almost nothing what people think and
that's a problem
sometimes when i i have to get my
headlights been i've been missing
headlight for a year
yeah and it looks it looks ridiculous
yeah right yeah so there's another side
to every one of these things
absolutely absolutely but all this to
say get rachel's book
yeah it's excellent we don't make any
money off of uh pushing rachel's book
that's
that's all on rachel you know but i
believe in
am really promoting life changing
products
and this book um is she doesn't know
we're talking about it but i just really
want to be like yo hey
i read it i brought it onto my show and
i don't just i don't bring personalities
on my show because of personalities you
got to bring something to my show that's
of substance
and the same thing with yours that's
right and i was like rachel we need to
talk about this because this is life
changing
and so get rachel's book daveramsey.com
today um oh i'm sorry daveramsey.com
go there today and get that book all
right let's um let's see here
let's go to uh christine in orlando
florida christine what is going on
hey guys thanks so much for taking my
call i'm
a little nervous but happy to be here um
i was wondering if you guys can help me
out i'm in a situation
and i'm needing some advice um i'm
mostly familiar with
dave ramsey's plan but do agree with the
fact that you know we should stay away
from credit cards
and i do stay with some credit cards but
i'm actually in a situation where
um i use my debit card to purchase a
trip in full
this was last year and it got campaign
understandably but my bank is telling me
that i'm unable to get my money back
because i use the debit card as opposed
to a credit card
so i'm not really sure what to do you
guys have any
advice or something never heard of that
at all
yeah what walk me through the process
okay the trip got canceled where were
you going
i was going to europe and i did pay in
full
through a company a travel company okay
you paid in full through a travel
company okay
so the travel company purchased a
all-inclusive trip
to a particular destination correct
correct correct so that's absolutely
true
you can't get your money back not
because it's on a debit card
but because travel agencies just like
airlines do not
issue a full refund past 24 hours
of their original booking and so you
should have a
credit from that travel agency from
and whatever particular airline they put
you on and from whatever particular
hotel they put you at
because of covet now you cannot get your
finances prime example i was supposed to
go to
um orlando uh this week i had already
bought the plane ticket but because of
covid
i am not going so i have a credit with
that particular travel company that
purchases my flights for me
um i can use that for down the road but
i cannot
get my money back and that was on a
debit card
and so if you filed a dispute because a
company would not will not give you back
the money
your bank is absolutely correct but what
i would do is i would reach out to the
travel company and say okay hey listen
you got a thousand
two thousand dollars of my money um and
i get it you can't it's your refund
because of covet but it's also not my
fault
do i at least have a credit and when
covert is over will i be able to use
that credit
so my guess yeah i think christine my
guess is that
they would have with a credit card
company you may have an opportunity to
dispute it and they're just going to
write you off whereas you paid cash and
um
your bank is saying forget you but it
sounds like the problems with the travel
company
yeah but even even if you did have a
credit card which i mean it's not going
to happen there too
here's why uh because the the company
has to issue back the money
okay and so if the company doesn't issue
back the money oh there you go i see
what you're saying
yeah the credit card or your debit card
is not going to give you back the money
yep
um yeah thanks guys i understand all
that um
the tricky part is i actually booked the
trip with my friend
and we were in the same exact situation
she disputed with her bank and she paid
with a credit card
she disputed with her bank and she got
her money back and fall
cool great so it sounds like she got a
provisional a provisional credit
not an actual reimbursement and banks do
do that
so what they'll do is when you put an
issue in when you put a ticket in
they will give you a temporarily credit
while they do the investigation that's
exactly i'm telling you right now
it happens all the time you did not get
your money back because you have a
debit card because what covers a debit
card and a credit card is that visa or
mastercard logo
okay so at some point they're going to
go back and say hey that travel company
still got a credit for you
yeah we're going to take that
provisional credit back away from you
right so the travel company's going to
say hey you know what they denied this
thing uh
you you're not doing the money back then
they're gonna take that money back off
of that her friend's credit card i think
i just learned something too here good
folks yeah
all right my good friend anthony o'neil
this has been the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
same part of the financial lives
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget friendly option and the original
health cost sharing ministry for
christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Music]
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from
laurie in virginia my brother and his
wife moved into our family home when our
mother was moved into assisted living
upon her passing the name was deeded to
him
and me oh they've been living there for
four years and it has been a safety net
for them due to some financial struggles
i don't know how to lovingly get out of
this financial relationship with my
brother
i would rather invest my half of the
home's value into our baby steps instead
of being a co-owner of this home
i know we should either sell and split
the proceeds
or he should buy me out of my half how
do i proceed without kicking them while
they're down
what do you think anthony
there's two sides of this thing i think
and you're the counselor here but i
think
that if you know they're down right now
and this house is helping them out and
it's not hurting you by helping them out
it feels kind of selfish to me okay
that's just my
original my my opinion it's like okay
this is not hurting you by letting them
stay there but you see this as an
opportunity to get money
to go benefit you personally and then
you're going to say hey listen let's
sell the house
or uh you buy me out that
it's about i when the house was given to
both of you so what i would say is one
just make sure to check your heart that
you're you're
you're wanting to do this for the right
reason and two there's nothing wrong
with just having a conversation with
with them saying hey this is what i
would like to do with with my portion of
the house
uh where are you all at in life how can
we you know
do y'all need another year two years can
we make a game plan like
just really having a good conversation a
healthy conversation because i do
believe
uh the breeding ground for understanding
and ending is communication
in the beginning that's right and so
just have clear communication
now but then before you have that
communication just make sure that your
heart is in the right place
and i i i think the most loving thing
you can do is to have a direct honest
empathetic vulnerable conversation
because if you're not having a love if
you're not having a conversation then
every family gathering for the last four
years there's a little bit of tension
yep every phone call you roll your eyes
you don't respond to text quite as fast
as you normally do right it starts to
seep into the
the all of the parts of the relationship
and then suddenly you find yourselves
with them and you
with that guy living in my house and
suddenly man
it's not your brother anymore it's just
some guy that's that's quote
quote-unquote taking money from you
right so the most loving thing you can
do anything you're dead on
sit down and have a conversation and i
don't know that you asked somebody
for what they're going to do right now
yes
yes i think it's fair to say hey my
name's on the deed of a house that i'm
not living in i don't feel comfortable
with that
let's talk a big picture you've been
living there four years what do you
think the plan is going to be i want to
get my name off that thing
and which you're well in your right to
do but also as anthony said
if you don't need the money and you just
want to get your share
man be honest and integris with your
with your brother yeah
all right and there's nothing wrong with
that my father dealt with that with his
sisters
i have 18 aunts and uncles and
when my grandmother passed she left the
house to all of them oh boy
and so you know they all had to have you
know a little
um uncomfortable conversation but one
thing what was so good and so fair
is they had the conversation that's
right and you can't do anything without
having the conversation right
and lori the most loving thing you can
do is not avoid it anymore
so great question i love it and um
i'd love to hear i'd love to know how
this conversation uh pans out give us a
shout back
all right let's go to eric in sarasota
florida eric what's going on how are we
doing
dr john anthony how you guys doing
excellent excellent how can we help
well uh my wife and i are on our journey
we're not having kids yet so we're
pretty young
in our mid-20s on baby step six really
excited of where we're going and
in the midst of that we have a strained
uh
slightly strained relationship with my
mother-in-law
and we have set up some good emotional
boundaries we got great people
counseling us and we are walking out
the relationship the balance points that
we can have
that's been great however my
mother-in-law just had a sudden
hospitalization which really scared her
she's already not financially stable
and she is now bringing up a
conversation
of putting us on her bank accounts
in order to you know as she's saying
protect against taxes
and we've told her we don't want to have
that conversation yet
and we're just trying to prepare in our
minds is there any merit should we just
move on and say no we don't want to do
this or is there something we should
really
talk to her about so she's asking you
to she's asking to put you on
or your wife on her checking account or
she asking
to combine finances with you and put her
name on your account
the first okay so i've heard this done
when
when um and it's been successful where
somebody finds out that there's medical
issues there may be
early stage dementia or alzheimer's and
we're going to get to a place where
they're going to need help or they may
be incapacitated and want someone else
to be able to just go to the bank
deposit checks pick stuff up
so that's not that big of a deal it's
when they want to
have access to your accounts that's when
i would hold the line
on that boundary okay um what do you
think anthony no i
i i i agree as well eric i don't see it
when my parents get to age to where
i need to be on their bank account so i
can have access to their funds to help
make decisions and move things forward
yes
um there should be no issues with that
um
at all uh there's nothing the only thing
that could come back though
is because if you're to add your name
then your social security number's going
to be attached to it with your social
security number
when the bank starts going overdrawn or
anything like that that
that could come back to you because your
name is on the account uh
but just make sure that you all just
have a clear conversation
and may and it sounds like your mom is
just trying to make sure that you all
have access
to her funds to help her out if anything
was to happen and
i think that's actually a great move
okay thank you guys all right you betcha
good for you man all right
um let's see here let's try to take one
more quick call let's go to christian
in dallas texas christian what's going
on man
hey guys thanks for having me you bet um
we're up against the clock so
give us your quick uh quick question
yeah definitely um just a quick
background
um i'm currently a rising senior at
richmond university over in london
um so i'm currently pursuing a degree in
international sports management
um but as of now um i've got forty seven
thousand dollars in
student loan debt and i'm taking a leave
without sleeping this semester
as a result of the national lockdown
that they've got in the uk now
um now i'm going to work as a ta to pay
down my current loan balance as there
are interest
um but since no one really knows when
everything will return back to normal
should i take an even longer break from
school to pay off my loans even further
or
just go back to normal in september and
allow that to continue to accrue
how much would it cost you to finish it
christian
um as of now i'm expected to graduate
with
around 70 000. so how much more cash
would you need to pay right now
or borrow right now um as of now for the
the ta we'll probably pay around 14 000
um so that'll be right my 9 to 5 for
this semester and then
i i still am interested in taking on a
part time during the week as well
cool yeah finish maybe get that up to 16
or 17 000.
yeah this semester alone that's fine
finish i want you to go ahead and finish
i don't want you get to your last
semester have all the student loan debt
and you do not have your bachelor's
degree
and so um what i'm saying is finish
and try to borrow as less as you
possibly can
but as soon as you graduate college you
need to get
gazelle about paying off your debt all
right
and so if you were telling me this is
your first year i would say heck no stop
but the fact that you put almost 40
complete years in
it's a graduate degree actually these
are the back end of last semester
of a graduate degree yes go ahead and
finish and then once you finish pay off
all of your debt do not get back into
school no more
bottom line love it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is joshua 1
9
have i not commanded you be strong and
courageous
do not be frightened do not be dismayed
for the lord your god is with you
wherever you
go maya angelou said
i can be changed by what happens to me
but i refuse
to be reduced by it come on mario i'm
gonna say that one more time
i can be changed by what happens to me
but i refuse
to be reduced by ah i like that
i like that i mean let's let's oh my
what
you know what it's it's almost like
in your counselors let me ask you this
question she said
let me read that let me say because i
just love this she said i could be
changed by what happens to me but i i
refuse to be reduced by it it's almost
like are we a product of
of our upbringing like do are we all are
we always going to be a product of how
we were raised
so something i say often is
you you get to choose your thoughts
and what's deeper than that is you get
to choose who hurts you
and i say i've said often dave can fire
me
he can frustrate me he can annoy me he
can take away my livelihood
but i get to choose whether he hurts me
and i decide
a very limited number of people in the
world who have permission to hurt me and
i actually went back and did a hard
exercise i learned this in a grad school
class i did a hard exercise i
called him and told him i want you to
know
i'm letting you way way way in my wife
this particular friend this particular
mentor you have access
to my pain and so if you ever call and
say hey you are not living up to who we
agreed
who you said you wanted to be right
i've given my wife permission to hurt me
and that's true vulnerability that's
true relationship right
but i limit that right because otherwise
i'm gonna let people on the internet
hurt my feelings i'm gonna let people on
instagram hurt my feelings i'm gonna let
politicians i disagree with people that
i don't know that well
you can frustrate me you can make me
change right yeah
you can take my job away yeah but i'm
not going to give you
i'm not going to give you way down my
heart right yeah
and my angela man man oh man oh man
i love it one after the other after the
other all right let's go to
kristen in chicago illinois kristen
what's going on
hi sean hi anthony happy friday
happy friday to you what's going on how
can we help
yeah so i have a question i'm about to
ask that i know doesn't necessarily have
the right answer
but rather to listen to the lord and
where he has me and act and wise counsel
give you some background i'm 29 i'm debt
free and single
i have six months of an emergency fund
and will have 20
down for a one-bedroom condo by july
and so my next step is to invest 15 in
retirement
as of july when i have my 21st cent down
but my question to you is whether or not
i should pull the trigger on the condo
if the direction of my life is kind of
unknown being single
not sure where god has me
i mean you're in a great place
financially
kristin um you know you're dead free
you're young
you are single um you know the dave
ramsey
people are always looking for single
people like you so you may not be single
much longer
um but you know
when you said that kind of creepy
anthony just don't put that out there
but go ahead
i'm just saying people on youtube are
listening to her they're going to google
it watch
um now when you say that you do not know
where god
has you i want you to break this down
for me a little bit more like are you
saying god may
uh you may move somewhere you may you
may get married here soon and you may
transition you know because i hear some
doubt inside of you and i'm trying to
understand that doubt a little bit more
before i give you my
my suggestion yeah you
hit that on the head with that but um i
was previously engaged that broke off
two years ago and so where i
thought my life was going and settling
down getting married
having kids so forth did not and so in
the last few years was just this
idea of could i just move across the
country you know
like experience something new like do i
want to purchase where
i grew up or so i don't quite know where
like the desires of my heart now or
where god you know wants to continue my
life at this point
yeah so i think this is a spiritual
question and a practical question
spiritual question is god what is my
purpose where are you taking me
practical where am i going to be
and so i i'm always suggesting to people
if you are
hesitant or doubtful that you're gonna
be in this place for at least
three to five years do not purchase
when you can answer this question as in
will you be here for at least three
years minimum
and if the answer is yes then proceed
forward in purchasing
if you're still like i don't know you
know
at the end of the year i may wake up and
decide and
find a great opportunity to move in
asheville tennessee or
uh to go to florida or you're not going
to california don't go to california
um you know you may go somewhere else
and so what i don't want you to do
what i what what i do not want to happen
is you're locked in
and now you can't move until you sell
your place
okay and so what i would recommend is
spend the next 90 days
just really dissecting your life see
exactly okay
um where where i'm going to go apply for
some jobs apply for some different
career
places and see where god leads you see
where you and god
land and if it's still there in in
chicago then yeah go purchase a home
now now i would advise you to speak to a
realtor
uh because one bedroom condos are real
hard to resell okay and so i'm
my whole thing is i purchase to resell
and right now bare minimum i don't
consider anything less than two bedrooms
because if i have a um if i sell it to a
husband and wife who don't have any kids
well one day they may want kids
and so they're going to want that extra
bedroom and so i would maybe even
consider
getting a two-bedroom condo that may be
just a few thousand dollars more
rather than just a one-bedroom but
that's just my advice that's not dave
ramsey's advice that's not
john the loneliness advice i'm just
saying as a young single guy
i'm thinking about okay when i go to
resell this
i need to be able to resell this for a
family not for another single
so that's just my my two neck is but
right now you need to spend the next 90
days
just really thinking about where you're
going to be kristen do you have somebody
speaking in your life with you that you
can be honest with and open with
oh totally i have a good church
community that
many women who are in my life to talk to
yeah what church do you go to there in
chicago
it's an evangelical free church called
the orchard okay
all right sounds good sounds good so you
have a great community uh just
continue to get wisdom and knowledge
from there so anthony
she asked a question that um i'm
embarrassed to say i've never
considered before after sitting on the
show for a year now
i've never felt the need to
do the next baby step just because i've
got the money to
right and so you
put your debt smalls to largest you get
a thousand bucks you pay your debts off
you get an emergency fund
you start investing i don't have to buy
a house
no you don't i don't have to
start a 529 plan if i don't have kids
right right
and so once you have these options right
once you've got a fully funded emergency
fund then you get to start dreaming like
she was doing but she was doing it
almost apprehensively like
i could just move anywhere yep yep i
could
i could go work over here or go live
over here and that's what we call
freedom
yes right yes because you've taken care
of this base
minimum stuff and maybe a one-bedroom
condo in downtown chicago
is a five-bedroom house in arizona or
austin texas or wherever that happens to
be right maybe so and i think the key
thing is man you just got to step back
and just
you know ask yourself some good
questions you know as a single man
um i i'm always asking myself okay cool
what's next
and then i'm also asking myself okay i
don't know when i'm going to meet my
wife
but will this decision that i make
impact my wife and my future family in a
positive way
or a negative way and so when i
purchased my home i built a
four bedroom home when i purchased my
town home downtown i purchased a
four-bedroom town home that's just me
because of where i'm
at i'm not saying everyone needs to do
that but i'm all i'm all
i'm already thinking about what i desire
okay i'm living below my means and i am
i'm creating space when god does send me
my wife
i have room for my life and my future
family
and so i think as young people we just
got to start thinking about
just ask ourselves some deep questions
and that's what my mentors asked me
that's what my pastor asked me
makes me think well i want to thank
producer james childs and associate
producer kelly daniel
thank everyone for sticking with us and
for calling in asking about your life
and your money enjoy your weekend find
some people
whether electronically over the computer
or in person
safely find people to spend time in your
heart
with i'm dr john delonie joined here
with my friend anthony o'neil we're
signing off this has been the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
you